when you were talking about Breaking Bad
you said that you know when Walter White
is kind of this downtrodden guy and in a
sense Walter White really did address
some serious issues teachers in this
country make [ __ ] livings they have to
go become meth dealers or whatever
dresses the whole drug problem in the
country I mean it was a pretty and the
health care system and the lack thereof
right Walter gets cancer and how's he
gonna pay for the treatments and that
becomes a that's what drives him crazy
right you clearly don't know who you're
talking to so let me clue you in I am
NOT in danger Skyler I am the danger
he said when you played Walter at his
kind of worst you were doing an
impression of your father because I
guess you assumed your father was sort
of a downtrodden guy he himself was kind
of a failed movie writer or movie dirty
want to be in the business right well he
was an actor for many years right and he
lived the the the typical actors life
where oh this was good we got a good
girl we had a battery or a bad Oh were
seer Bell that not bad here and so it's
up and down and up and down just God
still alive yeah he's still he's gonna
be 90 he's still alive and when he looks
at your career now huh do you get
embarrassed by your success and say oh
god this must be so difficult for my
father because this is all he wanted for
himself do you almost have to hide your
success from him no no he is so proud he
is oh yeah he's able to share it with
always say hey you did it son yeah he's
extremely proud and and it's really it's
really helped our relationship grow and
change and sustain because you had a
shitty relationship but you didn't talk
to him for years yeah well it's not that
I didn't talk to him is that he went
through a period where the career didn't
work out and he had an affair with
someone else and it split up the family
and yeah I mean he's nasty as did your
parents your mom and your dad have been
married seven times well together well
between the two of them seven times yeah
this must have been maddening to you it
was crazy
it was crazy yeah we your parents was
their first marriage to each other
no no so when they got when they had
their son you yeah you got siblings yeah
old
brother and younger sister they had
already been married in other families
not they didn't have other children
right but they've been married that we
knew like hippie artists like hey
anything goes let's get married let's
have kids let's get divorced let's Weber
uh no no as a matter of fact they were
really you know more on the conservative
side I mean they they met in an acting
class in Hollywood in like nineteen
forty eight forty nine so they both had
the acting bug exactly and both of them
didn't kind of make it right but in in
those days when they when they decided
to get married
you're either Joan Crawford you get say
to hell with my children I'm going to
write a star or you you quit the
business as a woman you quit the
business and you raise your fan that's
right that's what was expected so your
dad did the ultimate betrayal he things
were going poorly for him for whatever
the stress is she's got kids at home he
goes out and has an affair yeah
[ __ ] about the neighbor or what who
does he [ __ ] you know that's what it it
doesn't almost doesn't even matter it
was like it's you know I mean care
weren't you completely obsessed who's
this woman that is now my father's lover
no I was completely in denial
in fact kids around the neighborhood
said hey we don't see your dad anymore
what's going on I go oh he comes home at
night we play we have a good time so sad
there's one of those how old were you I
was about 9 or 10 when that started to
happen kids want to have a father they
want to have a good father so you create
in your mind a great father and remember
at the time a divorced family it was
very rare right then it now it's
commonplace yeah yeah but back then back
then you didn't want to talk about it
they're divorced the people who live
there were you able to go to your mother
and say hey I need help with this or do
you just you know it was a kid you're a
kid I didn't have anything to relate it
to it's just in fact in some ways you
think does every kid go through this is
it you know that's what you think is
happening so then there's a series of
your mom gets married again yeah dad
gets married again right but he he's off
your dad's off doing his thing he's not
even you gotta actually deal with the
people your mom brings yeah right your
dad wasn't calling you wasn't visiting
you nothing he's gone he's good how long
was he gone for he was gone for about
ten years and mother from
from when I was about 12 to 22 did you
hate this guy
no I wanted him because I had I had a
relationship a good relationship with
him as a boy and then you know something
happened in the off he went
do you ever say to your mother at that
period of yours where's that I mean can
we get in touch with them oh yeah that's
interesting I'm trying to remember what
the feeling was and I think I think it
just caved me and I just became
introverted about the whole thing right
you're very insecure about it you know
because you know as a kid that's
probably the worst age for the rug to be
pulled out for my friend just starting
to feel like oh this is what it is and
school and you're looking forward to
then middle school in high school and
and all of a sudden note